cette veste allait cesser de la
digitalisation de la société
capitale c'est le fait que
prélevez mensualisés sur sur les outils
et ces fêtes de la dématérialisation des
factures par exemple on sait plus de ces
usages là qui ont changé les
utilisations
[Musique]
usage chance pour autant
en réalité ce qui se passe c'est que un
certain nombre de produits se substitue
les uns aux autres donc hier vous
utilisiez que la marianne aujourd'hui
vous avez de multiples moyens
d'affranchissement vous avez des carnets
par exemple de table de correspondance
est que vous avez gagné bien évidemment
tous les outils digitaux
moi je suis arrivé il ya 25 ans donc il
est déjà que c'était fini
voilà et aujourd'hui on produit
quasiment autant de thèmes philatélique
album
je pense que la finale et il va
lentement and là ça reste le premier
loisir de collection en france
non